Let's see how you did with the concept map for
lesson three. Starting here with the human genome, there's 98%
of it approximately that's non-coding. It doesn't code for anything.
Then about 2% of it is protein coding. But all these
regions, as part of the genome, are actually made of
DNA, which we learned a lot about in lesson two. And
in lesson four, we will learn more about this non-coding
region. But here in lesson three, we learned about the protein
coding regions of the human genome, which are
divided into genes. Genes can have different sequences, so
they can have different versions. They can code for
different things, and we call these different versions alleles.
This is the word will keep coming back to
in this course. And alleles originate from mutations which
we'll learn about more in lesson six. Now, a
protein coding gene is composed of two major kinds
of sequence: introns and exons. The introns are spliced out
of the message that's going to be produced, and exons are going to be kept in
the messenger RNA, or mRNA. Now the process that synthesizes mRNA from
the gene DNA is transcription. And it's the first part of the central dogma.
Now, once you have an mRNA transcribed
from the DNA gene, it's going to be translated
by ribosomes into protein. Proteins are the
building blocks of cells. And the essential process
of genes to RNA or DNA to RNA to protein is called the Central Dogma.
Now, RNA is similar to DNA, in that
it's made up of nucleotides though not deoxynucleotides.
And there are four types of nitrogenous bases here. Adenine, which can base-pair
with uracil. Or U, a new nitrogenous base in the
RNA alphabet. And we still have guanine that compare with cytosine.
Now, our mRNA transcript is actually divided into
codons, which are groups of three letters of nucleotides.
There are a total of 64 combinations of
codons that are possible, based on this grouping of
three. And these 64 combinations are interpreted as
the genetic code. And in the genetic code, we
have three stop codons, one start codon, and
all the rest code for 20 different types of
amino acids. These amino acids make up proteins,
and these protiens are the building blocks of your
cells that make up who you are. I hope this helps clear
up some of the major concepts you learned about in lesson three.